we lost our mother
they're gonna bury her this weekend
I'm trying to raise money to get a plane
ticket to go out there to be with my
family so that we can hold a funeral
together as a family and barrier as a
family she would ask me what's going on
in my life and I would tell her about
what I'm doing in gaming how long have
you been doing this how come you're not
successful yet how come you're not
making money
therefore my mother passed she spoke
with the family about what is everybody
gonna do went on she's gone they were
talking about me and it was like
Triforce has been doing this Empire
Acadia thing for ten years and I really
haven't been profitable I have no kids
I'm single and you know I'm 34 now next
month I'm gonna be 35 but my mother told
them Triforce is in the Guinness Book of
World Records so it made me proud
the thing that makes that statement so
important to me isn't the fact that I
made her proud but the fact that she
recognizes me as Triforce
my mother worked two charity
organizations one in America and one in
Jamaica so she has always been a
contributor to society on a constructive
and productive level to help other
people so I try to model my organization
after the very same things that she did
but through gaining
the life that God gives us on this
planet is for us to enjoy all the
different experiences that we come
across no other experience of life is
greater than the time I am
no matter how rich you are no matter how
successful you are no matter what
adventures you go through in life you
have to go home and when you go home
your families at home video games is
like a framework to life it's like a
guide you start off your quest you have
a quest objective rescue the princess in
order to do that you need to level up
which requires money you're gonna have
some obstacles in your way left in the
future adversaries face the last boss
you beat the last boss and then rescue
the princess and you live happily ever
after that sounds like life to me
Triforce Johnson and Empire Arcadia is
recognized as having the most document
of tournament wins for a gaming team
with that record standing up 2,000 and
was achieved by Empire Arcadia as of May
14th 2015
these sports now is bigger than music
bigger than movies and bigger than
normal athletic sports so long live
eSports and long live Empire Arcadia
thank you isn't this your birthday
that's my birthday May 14th course I'm a
little older I wasn't born on 2015 all